[Music]
our very own cooking confidence coach
Nanny Bubby is back in studio thanks to
Chapman Automotive the sponsors of this
segment and today we are learning how to
make upside down cranberry apple
cornbread cake oh my God that's a
mouthful but you're gonna be so happy
when it hits your mouth we did not plan
that no no we did the Capricorn great
news I just want to spread the word uh
the nanny Bubby swag shop has just hit
nannybubby.com
swag spread love like butter apron
spread love like butter the best spatula
you'll ever use in your life you're
going to use it in a minute but more
importantly I thought about you when I
developed these These are cooking
confidence affirmation cards right and I
know you said oh my gosh I have to use a
mixer okay so I'm going to help you with
that this is how they work pick a card
any card there you go yeah they were fun
this is fun there you go but you have to
hurry yeah
all right now read it no not that side
there you go okay there is no end to my
creativity in the kitchen there you go
so now focus on that while we start okay
so ready here we go you like that yes
okay there you go and you two can have
them nannybubby.com okay so we're going
to start with this in one Skillet this
cake this is brown sugar cinnamon salt
we're going to melt the brown sugar into
the butter as it goes and then we're
going to take these Granny Smith apples
right show you they're green and we cut
them in slices and now we're going to
make ready concentric circles concentric
circles in the top on the top of the
brown sugar and the cinnamon and the
butter okay you want to help me with
that okay so concentric means they have
a common Center so around we go okay
okay there you go just around we go
that's it
yeah maybe but that's okay we're just
gonna fudge it just a little bit okay
and then we're going to take these
cranberries and we're just going to
sprinkle them all on top and then we're
going to make sure that they're just
nice and evenly spread out okay okay
there we go then we're going to take
this butter three quarters sugar yeah
start um well before you start with that
here let me just tell you one last thing
okay we're going to take flour baking
powder one teaspoon okay corn bread meal
cornmeal and salt mix it all together
whisk it together and now we're going to
add dry ingredients some wet ingredients
and dry ingredients into the butter and
sugar focus on your affirmation feel
calm start your engine I am a creative
start your engine baby okay low high
medium start on low so it doesn't fly in
your face or mine there you go keep it
down keep it down so you're going to add
this one half of this okay okay then a
half of room temperature milk okay okay
at four ounces now is there a reason why
we're going in this order
uh what order no you can try to
alternate yeah I usually start with dry
I don't know why and put that in then a
little more milk
there we go this is fun focus on your
affirmation you're doing so good okay
and now we're gonna add one egg at a
time okay I always drop them
individually make sure that they're good
because you don't want to ruin your hole
there you go look at that you're going
to work out okay you're getting so good
okay all right now mix that up okay all
right you're doing good all right a
little bit more maybe turn it up one yep
there you go see you've got this okay
this can go wrong yeah you're nobody
else it's going so right you've got it
okay all right let's cut it off okay so
we don't run out of the best part of
this okay boom boom somewhere we're
gonna layer this right on top whoop
there we go I don't want to drip all
over just a little we're gonna just put
this right on top okay okay spread it
around yeah well no just right on top
not layering just all of it on top okay
we're going to show you this because I
want to get to the best part here is it
finished okay now you're going to take
an offset spatula I know it's not
beautiful that smells amazing it does
right and it's warm so what we've done
is we have put holes in it and then
you're going to take the while it's
still warm however you open this maple
syrup and just pour it around let it
seep in which I've already done and then
we're going to take this maybe you can
help me with this okay okay now this is
live TV this is always frightening
will it work or will it not work I don't
know I don't know
so check out Nanny Bubby's kitchen and
Garden on social media and online at
nannybubby.com we also want to thank
Chapman Automotive for sponsoring that
segment Kendall there we go